what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest developments in
the epic attack on Titan story and
breaking down is definitely a good way
to put it since everything is breaking
down right now in the story quite
literally we have breaking alliances
breaking walls breaking armor and much
more along with some classic Titan
fighting action and important character
development we just witnessed a moment
which we've been waiting for for
seven-and-a-half years and for over 90
chapters in the story and I can't wait
to get into all of the hype and all the
excitement if you enjoyed the attack on
titan content on this channel and you
want us to keep it going please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications also a huge thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons who make
content like this video possible with
their support looking at how YouTube has
been cheating its non corporate creators
lately and this channel in particular
your support means more than ever thank
you so much finally this video will of
course contain attack on Titan manga
spoilers we're talking about the latest
reveals in the story so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
chapter one - four picks up where
chapter 1 2 3 left off except this time
we are taken back to labarie o on the
continent where the ldiots live there
are still coming to terms with what
aaron just said to them all
telepathically the fact that they also
heard the message confirms that aaron's
telepathic communication works long
range he can seemingly communicate with
all LD ins and Ackerman's even those who
are far away from the island we actually
see a glimpse of Annie's dad mr
leonhardt
in labarie oh he was apparently visiting
the local market and he had seemingly
dropped to his knees as he heard Aaron's
message this brief appearance of Annie's
dad is of course foreshadowing for
what's about to happen but more on that
later
back on Paradise Island where the wall
Titans are still stampeding gabby is
looking for Falco
mostly regenerated Reinard tells her
that this was Falco's first time
transforming into a Titan so he would
not be able to remember anything that
happened Reiner thinks Falco was
probably captured by Shawn and Connie
Reiner is also feeling really weak and
he tells Gabi that just as the walls
broke apart so did his Titan Armour as
the result he was injured by the falling
rubble that came off the broken wall
Gabi wants to kill Aaron to protect
everyone including her family back in
labarie oh but Reiner tells her that
it's pointless because Aaron has full
control of every subject of Amir the
southern destruction of his armor is
proof of that in Ryder's mind Reiner is
afraid that nothing will be able to stop
Aaron now and he says that their only
option is to run away he then loses the
remainder of his strength and he lays
down and falls asleep inside a house
where he and Gabi had taken shelter Gabi
then ties her hair up while looking into
a mirror very similarly to the way we
saw Aaron tie up his hair while looking
into a mirror back in chapter 106 Gabi
is also talking about not giving up as
she does this and Aaron was doing the
same Gabi was talking about not giving
up on Falco and Aaron was talking about
how they must keep fighting because if
they don't fight they cannot win after
that scene which establishes a clear
parallel between Gabi and Aaron Gabi
leaves Reiner to rest and she heads out
on her own she is determined to find all
their friends including Falco and Peake
and to get them all to safety but before
we move on I want to talk about that
brief scene where Gabi tied up her hair
while looking into a mirror I know it
seems like a minor detail but this brief
scene could actually be telling us a lot
more than we even realize now sure there
are a lot of parallels between Aaron and
Gabi
they both had difficult childhoods and
became child soldiers
they both had an enemy that threatened
their way of life and they were both
determined to destroy that enemy at all
costs after witnessing people close to
them dying as a result of a Titan attack
both Aaron and Gabi became bent on
revenge but eventually their characters
developed
yawn just being angry revenge-seeking
tweens so maybe this scene is just meant
to drive home the point that there are
many similarities and parallels between
Aaron and Gabi the only difference is
that they happen to find themselves on
the opposite sides of the same conflict
however knowing isayama I am a bit
worried that this scene could be
foreshadowing something a lot more
sinister what if I say imma is telling
us that the reason Aaron tied his hair
in that specific way while looking at
the mirror and talking to himself about
not giving up is because he is actually
recreating a future memory the future
memory of the next attack Titan user
Gabi Braun
what if si Amma is giving us a subtle
clue that by the end of the story
Gabi will eat Aaron and become the next
attack slash founding slash Warhammer
Titan which means that some of the
future memories that Aaron possesses are
not his own some of them belong to Gabi
I'll be real with you I think Gabi's
character has developed a lot and later
on in this video I will talk about her
character development and how she earned
my respect to an extent but with that
said would I ever want to see Kobe eat
Aaron no a thousand times no I certainly
hope that this is not how attack on
Titan will really end but if it does it
wouldn't be all that surprising knowing
how merciless asam is writing can be to
some of our favorite characters we'll
have to wait and see but I am definitely
hoping that I'm wrong on this one and
that this scene wasn't foreshadowing
that Aaron will be eaten by Gabi
sometime in the near future although the
whole concept of future memories and the
idea that Aaron might have been
recreating a future memory that belongs
to Gabi because she eats them in the
future is definitely concerning to me
elsewhere on the battlefield Armin
Mikasa Jean and Konya regroup on one of
the rooftops it turns out that John did
indeed capture on unconscious falco and
falco has been tied up and gagged by the
scouts Jean points out an interesting
and ironic fact the exact thing that
those people across the ocean feared the
most would come to pass now
thanks to what they did because they
were afraid of the audience on the
island and kept attacking them they are
now going to be destroyed by Aaron in
retaliation if they hadn't kept
attacking the Islanders and forcing them
into a corner they wouldn't have brought
about this catastrophe but with their
relentless hatred and repeated attacks
they turned the rumbling into a
self-fulfilling prophecy Arman still
thinks that this is too extreme Aaron's
apparent strategy would be an
unprecedented massacre but Aaron is
doing all of this in order to protect
the people that he cares about the most
knowing everything that we know about
the outside world this may be the only
way to realistically protect the people
that Aaron loves and that is the dilemma
no matter how hard the Islanders tried
to find a peaceful solution the outside
world including LD ends on the continent
and the people who advocate for the
rights of LD ins keep using the
Islanders as scapegoats for all of their
problems and they all seem to support
attacking parodies and destroying all
the LD ins on the island they all
continue to demonize the Islanders as
Devils and advocate for their
annihilation
I mean what would you do in that
situation what would any of us do first
you try to stay out of everyone else's
business by hiding away on an island
then you try to use the rumbling as a
deterrent then you try to find a
peaceful solution with the other nations
but none of this works they still keep
hating you and keep attacking you and
they won't stop until you and everyone
you care about is dead would you just
stand by and do nothing because you want
to keep your hands clean or would you
say screw it and do exactly what aaron
is doing it's not an easy choice by any
means now this part is very important
for some reason the pure Titans that
Zeke created are still attacking the
humans and not just the invading Marlins
but also the domestic soldiers and
Aaron's own comrades and this is
happening even though Aaron supposedly
has control over all of the Titans this
turn of events seems to indicate that
Aaron might not have full control over
the subject so Amir since he obviously
wouldn't have sent Titans to attack
Armin Mikasa and his other comrades
so our Aaron's power
actually more limited than we thought if
they are then maybe there is a way to
defeat Aaron after all even in this new
Titan form although we will need more
information before I make any such
speculations a new dilemma now emerges
for the scouts what do they do with the
captured Falco Kony wants to feed falco
to his mom's pure Titan form in order to
revive his mother but Arman warns that
this would cause additional conflict
with Reiner and Peake because they are
all very close to Falco Kony is still
clearly traumatized by what happened to
his mother and he still goes to visit
her at his village whenever he can you
will recall that she was turned into an
abnormal Titan who cannot move on her
own so for that reason she was not
killed but rather left inside the
village in her Titan state we really
can't blame Kony for wanting to bring
back his mother after all these years of
being forced to look at her in that
condition and yet being helpless to help
her sadly for Kony I sincerely doubt
that he will succeed in reviving his
mother from a narrative perspective she
is such a minor character and Falco is
far more important for the story Armin
Kony my corsage on and the other Scouts
jump into action in order to take down
the rampaging Titans at the same time
Jelena or yankin pawn and a bunch of
other soldiers are surrounded by Titans
inside a fort and they are basically
trapped with nowhere to go elsewhere
kaya is attacked by a Titan she is the
little girl who saved Gabby and Falco
earlier and the same girl who was saved
from a Titan by Sasha much earlier in
the story kaya thinks back to the time
when her mother was eaten by a Titan and
she was almost killed herself before
Sasha managed to save her
kaya calls out for Sasha to save her
once again but instead of Sasha who we
all know sadly is dead
kaya is saved by none other than Gabby
yes
Gabby who manages to shoot the Titan
through the mouth and then again through
the neck killing it ironically as she is
saved by Gabby kaya sees the image of
Sasha reflected in Gabby for a brief
moment kaya thinks that Gabby must be
her sister Sasha this is of course
ironic because
he was the one who killed Sasha and
everyone hates her for it but with that
said this moment is important Gabi's
resemblance to Sasha here is more than
just a passing detail this moment
emphasizes the idea that despite all the
things that she has done Gabi is not
necessarily a bad person she was just
doing what she thought was right based
on her specific life experiences and her
specific socio cultural context I know
this is going to be controversial
because we all hate what she's done and
how brainwashed she was at the beginning
but as hard as it may be we have to try
to put ourselves in Gabby's shoes we
know that she grew up with marlon
propaganda being hammered into her every
day from a very young age propaganda
which taught her that the islanders were
pure evil and that it was her duty to
kill them for the good of mankind
she then also witnessed the destruction
of lis burial and the deaths of many
innocent people including her friends
Sofia and odo at the hands of these same
Islanders Gabi did not get to see what
we saw Gabi did not see the suffering
that the Islanders themselves went
through as a result of Marla's attacks
on them she did not see the destruction
of shegaon chena district and the deaths
of all those innocent people including
Aaron's mom all Gabi could see was the
propaganda that was telling her that the
Islanders were evil when she then seized
the Islanders attacking Liberia without
having the proper context for why they
had to do it her belief that the
Islanders are evil Devils is confirmed
in her mind she then goes on to fight
the Islanders and she ultimately kills
Sasha but we can't ignore the context
within which Gabi is operating Gabi's
life story represents a critical lesson
about human nature and human history if
you form an opinion based solely on one
side of the story if you take everything
you hear at face value without
questioning it and if you don't have the
full info about the history and the
context of the situation it will be very
easy for someone to manipulate you and
get you to do horrible things without
even realizing it it's always important
to be skeptical to question and to do
your own research before forming an
opinion when the soldiers discover Gabi
and attempt to arrest her for being a
Marlin infiltrator
kaya Nicolo and the other members of
Sasha's family
hover for Gabi they say that she isn't
the Merlin but rather one of them a
member of their family this saves Gabby
from being imprisoned or possibly even
executed by the soldiers as they
evacuate the area kaya and Gabi discuss
why Gabi decided to risk her life to
save kaya and they talk about which one
of them is a devil kaya says that she is
a devil for trying to kill Gabi earlier
but Gabi says that no she is the real
devil because she killed so many people
just to make others happy just to please
the marlane military and be praised by
them ding ding ding ladies and gentlemen
we finally have a major character
development alert for Gabi we can still
hate what she's done
but clearly her character is finally
developing and evolving clearly she is
learning and we have to respect that
interestingly enough Nicolo says that
there is a devil inside all of us and
that is why the world turned out the way
that it did in the first place this is
another crucial lesson about human
nature and it applies to our own non
fictional world as well we all have
destructive selfish and aggressive
tendencies within us at least once in a
while and this leads to all the wars
suffering and destruction in the world
the world of attack on Titan always was
just a slightly more fantastical mirror
for our own world and I am fascinated by
how much reading the attack on Titan
story makes me think about our own world
and the issues that our own world is
facing meanwhile back at the fort
our boy shadow swoops in and kills a
Titan and he saves a bunch of soldiers
in the process I am guessing that these
soldiers are new recruits since they all
look pretty young and pretty shook up
mica says Jean Armand and everyone else
joined a fight in order to kill the
Titans before the Titans can consume
every human in sight all the Titans are
lured to the fortress where they are
killed with the help of vertical
maneuvering gear sharp blades and
thunder spears armin takes it upon
himself to personally put the Titan of
commander Pyxis out of its misery by
taking him out with a thunder spear he
thanks Pyxis for taking them all as far
as he did in his capacity as commander
and then Armin goes on to end the life
of the Titan Pyxis with a precise shot
from the Thunder spear it is
tragic death for such a memorable
character but a fitting one as well he
was given a quick and efficient death by
Armand before he could go on to consume
his own soldiers and subordinates and
that is definitely an end that Pyxis
himself would have preferred over the
alternative after the Titans are dealt
with Jelena and some of the volunteers
are placed under arrest
the other soldiers on the island aren't
too pleased when they realized that
Zeke's real goal wasn't the restoration
of aldea
but the sterilization of all LD ins
later Sasha's father leads Mekas on
Arman to where his family is hiding
along with Gabby Gabby asks where Falco
is and she says that she doesn't want to
fight anymore if they just let her and
Falco leave they will go away and they
won't bother anyone again
however Armin explains that Kony plans
to use Falco to revive his mother
Gabby loses it she drops to her knees
and begs for Falco's life she says that
Aaron should be able to just turn
everyone including Kony's mother back
into a human since he now has the
founding Titan power but Arman is
skeptical because if Aaron really
possessed that kind of power then why
wouldn't he just turn all the soldiers
that were turned into Titans by Zeke
back into normal humans again this as I
mentioned earlier is a very interesting
point and it suggests that Aaron's
founding Titan power may be limited was
Eren unable to turn these particular
Titans back into humans because they
were turned into titans by Zeke or is
there some other limitation that Aaron
has a limitation that we are not aware
of Gabi points out the riders armor
crumbled at the same time as the walls
crumbled so presumably this means that
Aaron has power over all titans and that
he deliberately caused the armor Titans
armor to fall apart but Armin isn't so
sure and he thinks back to Aaron saying
that all hardening would come undone and
he suddenly realizes that as the wall
crumbled and the armor titans armor
crumbled Annie's crystal must have also
crumbled the final page of the chapter
shows Annie lying on the ground her
crystal broken and he is finally awake
her eyes wide open after 90 chapters and
seven and a half years of real-world
time as well as like five years of in
story time
Annie is freaking back fun fact she was
initially encased in the crystal way
back in chapter 33 which came out in May
of 2012 she would remain in the crystal
until December of 2019 that's pretty
crazy when you think about it a massive
amount of time clearly this is extremely
hype
something that we've been waiting for
for so long and this makes chapter one
two for another incredibly memorable
chapter although they've pretty much all
been unforgettable in the past few
months so here are the big questions
that this chapter has raised first it
raised the question of whether Aaron's
newfound power is actually limited when
he first began transforming and
initiated the rumbling we were assuming
that he had unlocked the full potential
of Amir's power and that he would be
unstoppable
however this chapter has cast some doubt
on that due to the fact that Aaron
allowed the Titans created by Zeke
spinal fluid to keep rampaging and
attacking his comrades since we know
that Aaron is doing everything that he
is doing in order to protect his friends
it wouldn't make much sense for Aaron to
stand by and watch his friends get
attacked if he could easily just turn
those Titans back into humans so is it
possible that Aaron cannot turn them
back because Zeke was the one who turned
him into Titans in the first place and
Zeke's royal blood is some kind of
buffer to Aaron's power or is it just a
case that Aaron cannot turn any pure
Titans back into humans on his own we
assume that the founding Titans power
once fully Unleashed would be
practically unlimited but maybe there
are limitations that we still don't know
about or maybe the fact that Aaron
doesn't have royal blood still limits
his ability to tap into certain aspects
of the founding Titans power I'm sure
that we will find out more about this in
the next chapter and I am definitely
looking forward to that the second
question is about Gabby and what is
going to be her role in the rest of the
story and was ISA I'm a foreshadowing
that gabby is going to end up eating
Aaron obviously Gabby's character has
undergone a massive development and this
chapters certainly cemented that fact
her decision to risk her life to save
kaya and their interaction after that
has proven that gabby is finally
accepting the truth about Marla and
about
islanders and she is finally rejecting
the propaganda that was hammered into
her since she was a small child we also
know that Gabby's character has many
parallels to Aaron's character but is
that all or is Gabi going to eat Aaron
and become the next attack Titan
I love Aaron as a character as you guys
know so I definitely hope that doesn't
happen and although I respect Gabi more
after this chapter I'm in no way a fan
of Gabi but you just never know with he
Salma he loves to defy our expectations
and break our hearts let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
below did this chapter change your mind
about Gabi and do you think that she may
end up eating Aaron before the end of
the story was that scene where she is
tying up her hair while looking at the
mirror and talking about not giving up
just a shout-out to the Aaron scene from
chapter 106 or was it something more
was it a clue about Aaron's ultimate
fate in the story finally now that Annie
is out what is she going to do in my
video in Chapter one two three I said
that I believe Annie will return in the
next chapter because her whole
motivation was to save her father back
on the continent and now that Aaron
announced to all LD ins that he will
destroy everyone outside of the island
the parodies
Annie would have no reason to stay
inside the crystal on the contrary she
has every reason to emerge and try to
stop Aaron and save her father I was
right about any returning but what is
she going to do is she going to just be
super sad and depressed like Reiner
about everything that happened is she
going to try to actually fight Aaron is
she going to try to reason with Armand
I'm extremely curious to see what Annie
is going to do now after all this time
and after so much has happened while she
was stuck inside that crystal and I look
forward to seeing what you guys think
about Annie's big return
so do hit me up down in the comments if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more attack on titan content on this
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest attack on
Titan news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
page
to support our work and make videos like
this one possible with all the problems
facing YouTube right now patrons are
more important than ever and we really
appreciate it
special thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous fatty dolla beat Anatole
Cassatt's key alpha do on hell crews and
team Sparky 65 and I can't forget the
ones who rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to our the one and
tear patrons including Ingrid ah alone
out of Merrimack makoto-kun the world
Steelers and the school bus if you enjoy
our videos and you feel they provide
value for you please consider becoming a
patron even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]